salut vous savez quel jour on est
aujourd'hui le jour de vous donner des
nouvelles de mots q vous êtes habitués
maintenant tous les deux mois je vais
faire ma séance de laser pour faire
retirer le tatouage que je me suis fait
pour vous faire une petite vidéo et
comme tous les deux mois je vous fais un
blog pour vous raconter comment ça s'est
passé cette fois et puis pour vous dire
surtout si ça a marché
alors petit résumé des épisodes
précédents visuellement d'abord ça c'est
le tatouage juste après la séance c'est
à dire tout frais tout propre ça c'est
le tatouage
aujourd'hui c'est à dire après la
cinquième séance qui aura dû être
l'avant dernière mais j'ai appris la
dernière fois que finalement il faudra
être au moins 10 séances au lieu de six
au moins 10 donc ça veut dire après un
rapide calcul quatre séances
supplémentaires deux mois entre chaque
séance ça fait huit mois en plus ça veut
dire que je suis reparti pour pas loin
d'un an par le truc marrant c'est que
vous avez été hyper nombreux à m'envoyer
des petits type sein des conseils genre
des vidéos vous aviez vu sur des trucs
super efficace pour faire partir des
tatouages comme le mien genre une
machine dans un hall clinic à liège qui
apparemment est hyper efficace on a
d'autres qui m'ont envoyé des peaux
mates document envoyé des histoires
d'injection j'avoue potentiellement
peut-être que je vais tenter des choses
si vraiment la technique je suis en
train d'essayer actuellement marche pas
du tout mais pour l'instant je préfère à
persévérer dans la voie que j'ai choisie
au départ le truc marrant c'est que j'ai
reçue aussi un message d'un médecin qui
me propose de me faire partir le
tatouage au laser mais avec un laser a
priori différentes lui qui a utilisé en
ce moment en 3 séances seulement alors
il me dit par contre je te préviens tu
auras une petite trace cicatriciel alors
bon je vais recontacté pour en savoir un
petit peu plus c'est à dire quel type de
laser
est-ce qu'ils utilisent en quoi il est
différent de celui que le médecin actuel
utilise puis surtout qu'est ce qu'il
entend par une petite trace cicatriciel
parce que bon c'est à sa boîte mes
fesses c'est à dire un endroit qui voit
assez peu le jour j'ai quand même pas
envie de me retrouver avec scarface
scarface ou
[Rires]
j'avais testé le laser un lendemain de
cuite j'avais testé le laser pendant la
canicule j'avais testé le laser en ayant
très peu dormi là je vais tester le
laser le matin est malade puisque ça
fait une semaine peut-être que ça
s'entend à ma voix que je me traîne une
bonne vieille branche it des familles
donc voilà petit petit piment
supplémentaire petites expérimentations
en plus donc là je vais me coucher je
vais manger avant vous inquiétez pas je
peut-être même aller boire un p'tit coup
on ne sait pas je vais faire une bonne
nuit de sommeil et on se retrouve demain
matin pour la séance
[ __ ] ça pique un peu tôt
[Musique]
et c'est reparti
on
[Musique]
on produit de beauté parce qu'en plus il
faut se créent mais les faits ça pique
un peu tendance à soi bon voilà ça s'est
terminé alors première chose que je fais
en rentrant général c'est de retirer le
pansement parce que je suis un petit peu
allergique à tout ce qui est ce par
hadra adhésifs etc donc j'enlève le
pansement raison pour laquelle j'ai
racheté de la pommade parce que comme ça
j'en profite pour changer la bonne
couche de tomates qu'il faut se remettre
tous les jours et même plusieurs fois
par jour pour aider à la cicatrisation
du coup pas de pansements plus plein de
peau mate je vous laisse imaginer l'état
donné ce clip cr bonheur est dans le
petit bilan de la séance alors d'abord
fun fact je sais pas si je vous en avais
déjà parlé mais le médecin laseristes
c'est le sosie de liam neeson et puis
deuxième fun fact dit m'a dit quand je
suis arrivé et que j'ai baissé mon slip
un parce que c'est ce qui se passe dans
ces moments là alors comment va le
capitaine haddock donc le mec est
persuadé que je me suis tatoué le
capitaine haddock sur le cul il a
augmenté un petit peu la puissance à
d'ares 1 x vous rappelez il avait
augmenté la taille du faisceau là cette
fois il a gardé donc la même taille de
faisceaux mais augmenter la puissance ça
n'est pas encore flagrant 1
je vous montre à quoi ça ressemble
immédiatement après la séance
c'est à dire juste après avoir lui même
en ce moment là ça ressemble à ça c'est
à dire que c'est assez gonflé tout
autour du de lancre mais que l'anc renom
tu vois bien qu'elle n'a quand même pas
encore éclaté en mille fragments donc
cette fois encore c'était bien
douloureux je pense quand même que je
commence à m'habituer parce que
franchement j'ai l'impression d'avoir
une normale que la dernière fois alors
qu'il a augmenté la puissance de la
machine
donc bon la bonne nouvelle la mauvaise
nouvelle c'est qu'on a rediscuté du
nombre de séances il m'a dit que
effectivement donc comme il l'avait dit
la dernière fois on est plutôt sur dix
et même potentiellement sur encore plus
que ça voilà bah on fait comme
d'habitude là vous avez vu à quoi ça
ressemblait juste avant
là je vous ai montré à quoi ça
ressemblait juste après demain et après
demain je vous montrerai à quoi ça
ressemble et puis on fera un petit bilan
à la fin donc aujourd'hui je vais vous
laisser on en reparle on en reparle dans
deux jours donc ça c'est en effet ce
juste après la séance de tatouage c'est
à dire à quoi il ressemblait au tout
début ça c'est mon tatouage juste avant
la séance de laser du jour ça donc c'est
le tatouage juste après la séance c'est
à dire une fois que j'avais enlevé le
pansement
là vous avez mes fesses et le tatouage
qui va avec le lendemain de la séance de
laser et là c'est le tatouage deux jours
après les séances de laser et donc voilà
à quoi ça ressemble à j + 2 c'est dingue
un fait partie pratiquement complètement
mais tout d'un coup quoi non c'est faux
c'est un franck évidemment ça n'est pas
du tout partie plus que les fois
précédentes donc petit résumé
j'ai repris rendez-vous pour dans deux
mois pour la sixième séance qu'il aurait
dû être la dernière confirmation que
donc il y en aura manifestement au
minimum quatre de plus et même sans
parler d'argent j'avoue que je commence
à me dire il n'y a pratiquement aucun
effet au bout de cinq séances
est-ce que 5 de plus vraiment ça va
faire partir complètement ce tatouage
je ne sais pas et puis il ya donc ce
brave ce brave laseristes qui ment rien
messager qui me propose de me faire tout
partir avec un laser différent en trois
séances seulement mais avec un petit des
petites traces cicatriciel donc géré
depuis échangé un peu avec lui il me dit
que donc effectivement il y aurait des
cicatrices que je n'ai pas encore vu je
vais lui demander d exemple
et qui seraient des cicatrices
définitive donc la question que je me
pose et je vais vous demander de je vais
vous mettre à contribution là dessus
c'est après la prochaine séance qui
aurait dû être la dernière et qui
manifestement sera pas du tout la
dernière est-ce que je continue la
méthode actuelle c'est à dire je repars
pour 4 de plus et on verra où est ce que
je tente la proposition de l'autre
médecin c'est à dire un autre laser qui
est censé tout me faire partir en trois
séances
mais potentiellement avec des cicatrices
donc évidemment j'aurais la décision
finale et ce sera notamment en fonction
de la tronche des cicatrices que
j'espère bien voir d'ici là mais j'ai
quand même envie de vous demander votre
avis et pour ça je vais vous donner
rendez vous sur mon compte instagram
vous allez sur instagram vous tapez j m
nl
voilà c'est comme mon compte twitter cjm
nl @ jam et neil je ferai un petit
sondage dans ma story à l'heure où vous
regardez cette vidéo d'ailleurs le
sondage
sera déjà en ligne je vous demande tout
simplement de dire oui continuez comme
ça c'est à dire quatre séances de plus
du même du même laser ou nos tentes
autre chose voilà en sachant que
éventuellement si après ça ne marche
toujours pas il reste encore d'autres
techniques mais nous on n'en est pas là
voilà et bien écoutez dtc c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très
bientôt pour une vidéo évidemment vous
le savez mieux tout le monde d'ici là
qu'est ce que vous faites vous mettez
bien surtout portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]